the Joe Rogan experience roll whatever
that is rock stars yeah here's the
problem we know too much about them all
the mysteries gone you know it used to
be like Robert Plant would come down and
[ __ ] magic carpet we didn't know
where he's coming from you know at the
time thought he was on one yeah talk
about Robert Plant in his prime right
who the [ __ ] ever saw anything like that
before they were taking Elvis off the Ed
Sullivan Show because he was shaking his
hips Robert Plant has got a piece on him
and it's pressed up against his pants
his pants are tight as a glove he's got
no shirt his like his shirt is
completely open right he's completely
bare chested long hair and a voice that
you never heard before he never heard
someone sing like hold on love
I mean it's just he's doing something
different he's got some new thing going
on and you don't know [ __ ] about him
there's no [ __ ] podcast that he does
he doesn't have a Twitter page we said
stupid [ __ ] about Trump let's see they
they actually did they never did any
interviews kid and he raided and
released singles yeah actually a lot of
people didn't know you hear all these
classic songs on the radio now but
they'd never put single they refuse to
do singles they didn't do press dude you
wanted to see Led Zeppelin you had to go
to the show
yeah look at his [ __ ] look look at it
look at his car he wants you up against
his pants course he does I mean I don't
know if he had a sock there but I want
to believe I want to believe that he was
just out there slinging dick a dude was
like 17 when that first record came out
imagine he wasn't even the first choice
they went through a few people Jimmy
Page did when he put the band together
one of my favorite singers of all time I
love Robert Plant would always felt like
if Steve mariette I always wanted to
hear what that would sound like his heat
into the guy from humble pie [ __ ]
incredible voice was he supposed to be
I'm not I want to say maybe page one on
him but he couldn't do it I know they
talked to maybe Rod Stewart was it faces
at the time or earlier they were there a
what I know Robert Plant wasn't choice
number one can they had to talk Bonham
into taking the gig page and John Paul
Jones have known each other through
session work in the mid-60s and and when
the yardbirds broke up jimmy somehow
thought he had rights the name and he
wanted to put together
like a super ban of all his the favorite
his favorite musicians he played with
and Bonham was recommended by the bass
player John Paul Jones if they had to go
and like talk him into it because he was
playing when bands at the time I paid
him a lot more money Wow I'm Jimmy's I
got to explain what they were trying to
accomplish and sell him on the idea but
that was that was sort of a like
everybody talked like bands that are put
together by labels it wasn't Jimmy Page
was a genius and a very you know
visionary kind of guy so he knew he
needed to build this band to take over
the world that's what he did Wow
great producer too - [ __ ] phenomenal
guitarist right probably one of the most
inventive guitar players ever a lot of
people say it sometimes especially later
when he's on morphine some sometimes it
can be a little sloppy but I like that I
like I hate perfect mmm oh nothing more
boring than perfect so is that is the
sound of a guitar similar to like a
voice like sometimes to do to have a
raspy crazy [ __ ] up voice and it just
makes it right I mean yeah any real
artist player with an instrument it
doesn't matter what the guitar is with
amp or anything like anybody that has
their thing they can pick up anything
and within like three notes you just
know it's that person
[Applause]